loser Django
that was that the end of the world
November 25th 1963 Dallas ten days
earlier I need to find
[Music]
[Applause]
all right first off I want to say we
brought the end of the world back here
with us oh my god again my cult is gonna
be so pissed I told him we had until
2019 we have until Monday everything in
our life is connected from the plot to
assassinate the president that can't be
a coincidence
you're supposed to be here right we know
something changes in the timeline
to make it right again before everyone
and everything we know is dead
[Music]
I'm not here to sell vacuum the
Commission will hummus down wherever and
whenever we go
[Music]
I need a spotter what is that like a
wingman I don't know anything I know
everything you are an open book written
full of very dumb children class spent
here no unfortunately ghosts can't time
travel are you kidding me
[Music]
all right quick rundown Luther
super-strength Klaus can come in with
the dead Alison to whom or anyone to do
anything except she never uses it
[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
gonna be my umbrella academy season 2
trailer Netflix just dropped a whole
bunch of new footage so we'll break it
down it's been a while since season 1
but I will be doing some videos for the
season 2 episodes later this month when
all the episodes drop so if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos if you never read the
comic book or you've completely
forgotten what happened during season 1
because it's been so long they're
basically a parody of Marvel's x-men
like you have a gifted school for
youngsters a version of Professor X but
it's so much weirder so then like that
not-safe-for-work x-men and you even
have Kitty Pryde one of the former x-men
from the x-men movies the big thing with
season 2 is that now that they've time
shifted or they time traveled back into
the 1960s and they're moving through the
comic book story but they are changing a
lot about the comics that they're
adapting the volume they're adapting for
season two is called umbrella academy
Dallas as in Dallas Texas as you see
during the trailer during the 1960's
there are a couple really big things
that happened in Dallas during the
1960's that they referenced during the
timeline here in the trailer so when
number 5 jumps in is like where am I
what's going on here everything seems
like it's in chaos the person there
tells him that the world's going to end
November 25th 1963 the reason why that
date might sound familiar to you is
because it's just a couple days after
JFK was assassinated in Dallas Texas so
obviously in the trailer you kind of see
them reference it it'll be a big part of
the seasons plot but then you see all
these Soviet communists invading so
apparently whatever happens to lead to
JFK's assassination in the aftermath it
causes the cold war with the Soviet
Union to turn into a full-blown war
mutually-assured nuclear destruction
with that giant mushroom cloud going off
like they said at the end of season 1
they failed to prevent the end of the
world and now they've just postponed it
and has followed them into the past
they're changing a lot about the comic
book plot of umbrella academy Dallas so
if you did read the comic book
there will be a lot of differences
there's way more time shifting it gets
way more complicated so these are just
simplifying a lot of that story line the
big twist at the end of the trailer is
them meeting the younger version of
Hargreaves who's still alive at this
point with the younger version of Pogo
who's still alive he was killed during
season 1 along with Hargreaves they tell
him about who he is what the school is
the Umbrella Academy itself and why he
needs to adopt those 7 children so
that's how he winds up knowing which
special children to adopt during season
1 there were 43 all born on the same day
around the world so he goes around
adopting 7 special ones but now we know
it's because they told him which wants
to adopt you need to adopt all of us
that's why during season 1 you see him
inspecting all the babies with that
special monocle just to make sure that
it's the right ones that he's adopting
if you're not really familiar with the
characters or you skipped a lot of
season one Luther's number one he's
super strong he also had his head
transplanted onto the body of a gorilla
after he had an accident in outer space
number 2 is Diego he's just really
awesome with knives
number 3 is Alison who has the power of
suggestion using rumors she can make
people do what she wants if she repeats
the phrase I heard a rumor before she
says the action that she wants them to
take like the end of the trailer where
she says I heard a rumor quote-unquote
that you punched yourself in the face
and then he pushes himself in the face
at the end of season 1 Vanya actually
slit her throat to prevent her from
using her power but it seems that she
gets her voice and her powers back
during season 2
number 4 is Klaus he's usually super
high but he can also talk to the dead
the goes that they referenced during the
trailer that keeps following him around
and follows him around during season 1
is actually the ghost of one of their
former brothers in the Umbrella Academy
program number 6 he died a long time ago
though the other cool side effect of
Klaus is necromancy powers is that he
can actually channel the powers of the
dead spirits if they has special powers
themselves so these powers aren't Klaus
as natural powers they're number 6 his
powers even though he's dead he's still
able to use them number 5 is the time
traveler he drives most of the plot
during season 1 season 2 his powers are
self-explanatory he also worked for the
Commission briefly they're the same ones
that are chasing them down during season
2 they were kind of the antagonists
during season 1 they're kind of like
sinister versions of time cops in the
world of the Umbrella Academy they try
to protect the timeline but they're also
not above manipulating the timeline to
benefit their organization number seven
is Vanya the white violin she has sonic
based abilities and is super powerful in
terms of x-men Marvel Easter eggs she'd
be like an omega-level mutant
she's also played by Kitty Pryde as I
said from the x-men movies I don't know
how much they're changing her storyline
during season two from the comics
because she actually has amnesia after
this big catastrophe at the end of
season one so she doesn't remember going
full evil to try and destroy the world
it's kind of hard to tell if she has
amnesia based on this trailer footage
but it seems like she's pretty chill so
I'm assuming that she might have a
little bit of amnesia and just not
remember that moment the whole thing
with the end of the season though is
that number five had actually intended
on jumping them back in time into their
child bodies so that they could just
restart and try to save the world again
instead though it seems like they all
just wind up in the past straight up
Klaus becomes a cult leader like he has
that funny moment in the trailer when
they find out the world's going to end
in 1963 and he gets all upset oh I told
my cult that the world wasn't going to
end till 2019 Allison seems like she
gets into some sort of romance and
involved in the civil rights movement
Luther becomes a fighter for money he
actually takes his jacket off too they
spent way more money on the special
effects budget or maybe that's just some
prosthetics that they put on him number
six is still dead but he's still
ultimately following Klaus around
because he's the only one who can
perceive him like they have that funny
slap fight there so if you were to walk
by Klaus on the street there it would
look like he's slapping nothing Diego
winds up in a mental institution it
looks like the girl that he winds up
getting into a relationship with also
follows him around so she becomes a bit
of a character during season two as well
then Vanya seems like she is driving
around with his family maybe trying to
get back to the rest of the group but
like I said the people chasing them
through the trailer with the guns are
the Commission the whole joke about
Diego being a very dumb book written for
children is just the writers making a
joke about the Umbrella Academy comic
books that the show is based on in just
comic books in general books written for
children haha quote-unquote some of this
will seem very different from the comic
book plot it's not gonna be quite so
complicated as the comic book story but
if you spotted any big Easter eggs that
I didn't mention during the video just
let me know in the comments there's some
really cool weird
stuff in the comic books that I'm hoping
will show up in the episodes the season
is gonna premiere july 31st they'll be
dropping all the episodes the big stuff
that's coming up after this is actually
gonna be the boys season two episodes in
early September then we have the
mandalorian season two episodes from
Disney Plus then we have all the big
Marvel Disney Plus shows they haven't
given us a full schedule for the rest of
the year on that stuff but there'll be a
bunch of big stuff happening the second
half of the year so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you should
see all those videos when I post them
every one click here for that brand new
trailer for the boys season 2 and click
here for that Michael Keaton Batman
deleted scene from crisis on Infinite
Earths thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]